STRENGTH AND A CLEAR, CLEAR
DELINEATION OF WHAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED OF NORTH KOREA IN ORDER
FOR THE SUMMIT TO TAKE PLACE.
>> Judge: ALL RIGHT,
THANK YOU, DANIEL.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S TOUGH TALK
TODAY WITH NORTH KOREA SHOULD
NOT COME AS A SURPRISE, IT'S AN
MONTHS.
REMEMBER THIS?
>> President Trump: WE ARE
SETTLING, AND WE WILL DO
SOMETHING NOW.
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER, WE HAVE TO
DO SOMETHING.
WE CANNOT LET THAT SITUATION
FESTERED, WE CANNOT LET IT
HAPPEN.
THE LITTLE ROCKET MAN, IS A SICK
PUPPY.
NORTH KOREA IS A COUNTRY RULED
AS A CULT.
AT THE CENTER OF THIS MILITARY
CULT IS A DERANGED BELIEF IN THE
LEADER'S DESTINY TO RULE AS
PARENT PROTECTOR OVER A
CONQUERED KOREAN PENINSULA, AND
AN ENSLAVED KOREAN PEOPLE.
THIS MAN WILL NOT GET AWAY WITH
WHAT HE IS DOING, BELIEVE ME.
AND IF HE UTTERS ONE THREAT IN
THE FORM OF AN OVERT THREAT --
WHICH BY THE WAY, HE HAS BEEN
UTTERING FOR YEARS AND HIS
FAMILY HAS BEEN UTTERING FOR
YEARS.
OR, IF HE DOES ANYTHING WITH
RESPECT TO GUAM OR ANYPLACE ELSE
THAT IS AN AMERICAN TERRITORY OR
AN AMERICAN ALLY, HE WILL TRULY
REGRET IT.
AND HE WILL REGRET IT FAST.
>> Judge: JOINING US NOW WITH
REACTION ARE A FLORIDA
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSIONAL
CANDIDATE LIEUTENANT COLONEL
MICHAEL WALT'S, COAUTHOR OF THE
REAPER, AND U.S. ARMY VETERAN
AND BRETT VILLA COVE H.
ALL RIGHT, GENTLEMEN, I'M SURE
YOU HAVE KEPT UP WITH THAT AS I
HAVE.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE A GAME OF CHESS
AND DO SOMETHING DUMB LIKE THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT IS THE WAY
NEGOTIATIONS HAVE TAKEN PLACE IN
THE PAST.
GENERAL, I WILL TALK WITH YOU
FIRST.
THERE IS SOME DESTRUCTION OF
NUCLEAR SITES AND THEY PROMISED
TO DESTROY MORE.
HAVE WE GIVEN UP ANYTHING IN
EXCHANGE FOR THAT?
>> WE HAVE GIVEN UP NOTHING, WE
HAVE GOTTEN EVERYTHING THAT WE
COULD HAVE WANTED BEFORE THIS
SUMMIT HAPPENED.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS, THE ART
OF THE DEAL IN ACTION HERE,
JUDGE.
LIVE BEFORE OUR OWN EYES, FOR
THOSE WHO DIDN'T READ THE BOOK,
THEY GET TO KNOW WATCH THE MOVIE
THEY GET TO KNOW WATCH THE MOVI
MOVIE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP UNDERSTANDS THAT
HE IS IN THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF
THE WORLD, AND HE MENTIONS
700 BILLION TWICE DURING HIS
PRESS CONFERENCE TODAY.
THAT NUMBER IS THE SIZE OF OUR
DEFENSE BUDGET.
AND THIS WAS STRATEGIC MESSAGING
TO NORTH KOREA.
HE UNDERSTANDS A LEVERAGE OF
WHAT HE HAS HERE, AND THAT
7 BILLION NUMBER IN OUR DEFENSE
BUDGET IS 25 OR 30 TIMES THE
SIZE OF THE GROSS DOMESTIC
PRODUCT OF NORTH KOREA.
SO IF YOU ARE ON THE
NORTH KOREANS DIED AND YOU HEAR
THAT NUMBER, THAT'S AN
OVERWHELMING FIGURE.
THEN, HE JUST MAGICALLY WEAVES
TOGETHER THE DIPLOMATIC
INFORMATION, MILITARY AND
ECONOMIC ELEMENTS OF NATIONAL
POWER.
AND REALLY THAT'S THE MAXIMUM
PRESSURE CAMPAIGN THAT HE
REFERENCED IN HIS SPEECH TODAY.
>> Judge: ALL RIGHT, BRETT.
I WILL GO TO YOU.
THE ROLE OF CHINA IN ALL OF
THIS, THE PRESIDENT SEEMS TO
HAVE INDICATED THAT AFTER A
SECOND MEETING WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF CHINA, THAT
KIM JONG UN SEEMS TO HAVE
CHANGED HIS TONE.
HE SIGNALED THAT, I BELIEVE IT
WAS YESTERDAY.
>> I'VE BEEN PLAYING PUPPET
MASTER THIS WHOLE ENTIRE TIME.
FROM DAY ONE THIS HAS BEEN JUST
AS MUCH A NEGOTIATION WITH CHINA
AS IT IS WITH NORTH KOREA.
DO YOU THINK THAT CHINA WANTS TO
SEE THOUSANDS OF U.S. SOLDIERS
OFF OF THEIR BORDER?
THEY'VE BEEN PLAYING US ALL
ALONG AND WE HAVE TO BE VERY
CAREFUL WHAT WE DO HERE.
BUT WILL BE HAVE SEEN WITH ALL
THESE TALKS IS, WE HAVE BEEN
WITNESSING TODAY MASTER CLASS IN
NEGOTIATION THAT HAS BEEN
PLAYING OUT ON THE WORLD STAGE.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS, THESE
DEALS ARE ALL ABOUT LEVERAGE.
WE ARE THE STRONGEST COUNTRY IN
THE ENTIRE WORLD.
WE DON'T NEED TO LISTEN TO A
COUNTRY, OR BOW DOWN TO A
COUNTRY THAT HAS THE ECONOMIC
GDP THAT IS LESS THAN THE SIZE
OF HONDURAS.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT WHEN IT COMES
TO ALL THESE TALKS THAT TRUMPETS
CAREFUL ABOUT BEING TOO
ACCOMMODATING TO KIM JONG UN
BECAUSE IT RISKS THIS
RECOGNITION FOR HIM, OF WHAT HE
HAS BELIEVED IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
ALL ALONG WHEN IT COMES TO
HAVING THIS NUCLEAR ARSENAL.
THIS DEAL HAS TO GET DONE BUT IT
NEEDS TO BE DONE RIGHT, OR NOT
AND IN THE END WE ARE TAKING
BACK CONTROL.
>> Judge: MICHAEL, I WANTED TO
ASK YOU.
THIS MORNING THE PRESIDENT PULLS
OUT OF THE SUMMIT.
THE LAST THING TONIGHT IS,
NORTH KOREA IS SAYING, WE ARE
READY TO SIT DOWN AT EVERY TIME.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR PEOPLE
IN THE MILITARY?
THAT IS YOUR BACKGROUND, THAT'S
WHO YOU ARE.
WHAT'S GOING ON AT THE PENTAGON
RIGHT NOW?
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS SHOWN
STRENGTH FROM DAY ONE AS
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF, AND I THINK
HE HAS BEEN ABSOLUTELY RIGHT ON
NORTH KOREA AND SENSEI ONE,
DESPITE ALL HIS CRITICS.
THIS IS NOT PRESIDENT OBAMA WHO
WILL TAKE THE OFFER OFF THE
TABLE, PRESIDENT TRUMP KNOWS AND
HAS ALWAYS KNOWN THAT DIPLOMACY
NEEDS CREDIBLE USE AND NEEDS A
CREDIBLE THREAT OF MILITARY
FORCE.
NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE THAT BUT THE
NORTH KOREANS HAVE SEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP TRAIN AND EQUIP
AND FUND OUR MILITARY.
SO HE HAS COME INTO THIS WITH
THREE KEY CONDITIONS, AND THAT
MILITARY EXERCISE IS WITH OUR
MILITARY ALLIES AND JAPANESE
ALLIES WILL CONTINUE.
DENUCLEARIZATION MEANS EXACTLY
THAT, THAT IT IS FULL VERIFIABLE
DENUCLEARIZATION AND THAT KEY
HERE IS THE SANCTIONS WILL
CONTINUE.
SO WHAT DO I HOPE TO SEE NEXT
FROM MY COMMANDER IN CHIEF?
ANOTHER ROUND OF SANCTIONS, THE
7TH FLEET SITTING OFF THE COAST
OF NORTH KOREA.
AND FOR EVERYONE CALLING HIM A
WARMONGER, THEY ARE ABSOLUTELY
WRONG.
THIS PRESIDENT KNOWS ITS
CREDIBLE USE AND THAT THE
VETERANS A REALLY LONG.
WILL DOES IT ACTUALLY MEAN PEACE
WILL DOES IT ACTUALLY MEAN PEAC
PEACE?
>> Judge: WHAT ABOUT
GENERAL KATO, THERE HASN'T BEEN
A FIRING AREA IN LUNGS.
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
LEFT THAT WAS REJOICING THIS
MORNING, JUST TO DIGRESS, THEY
DEFENDED HAMAS, THEY DEFENDED
MS-13 AND THEY HAVE DEFENDED NOW
KIM JONG UN IN NORTH KOREA, ALL
IN THE SAME MONTH.
THAT'S PRETTY AMAZING IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT.
BUT THERE HAS BEEN NO ACTION
FROM NORTH KOREA MILITARILY.
AND AS MICHAEL JUST MENTIONED,
WE KEPT DOING OUR MILITARY
DRILLS, WE KEPT APPLYING OUR
PRESSURE AND WE ARE TIGHTENING
THE SCREWS EVERY DAY.
AND THAT IS THE LEVERAGE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS.
AND HE HAS -- KNOWS HE HAS A
AND YOU WALK AWAY FROM THE DEAL
IF THAT'S WHAT YOU WANT TO.
AND IT'S VERY TEXTBOOK WHAT HE
IS DOING.
SO HE KNOWS HE'S GOT THE
LEVERAGE AND HE IS EXECUTING
BASED UPON BEING THE LEADER OF
THE MOST POWERFUL COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD.
AS OPPOSED TO APOLOGIZING, AND
SENDING PALLETS OF CASH TO GET
DETAINEES BACK AND ALL OF THAT
INSANITY.
>> JUDGE, IF I COULD REMIND
EVERYONE, PRESIDENT REAGAN
WALKED AWAY FROM THE SUMMIT WHEN
I TRIED TO MOVE THE GOALPOST AND
THAT'S EXACTLY HOW
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ACTING.
>> I ONLY HAVE ABOUT 16 SECONDS
LEFT.
AS WE CONTINUE WITH THIS TARIFF
BACK AND FORTH, CHINA IS SENDING
US A SIGNAL, ALSO, BY SAYING
THAT WE CAN MANIPULATE
KIM JONG UN.
CORRECT?
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
AND I THINK THAT'S THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM, YOU ARE NEGOTIATING
WITH A SUPERPOWER.
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS,
OUR MILITARY IS READY.
YOU HOLD THE CARDS RIGHT NOW AND
WE LEFT THIS DEAL ON OUR TERMS.
RIGHT NOW WE ARE IN THE BEST
POSITION WE CAN BE FOR THESE
NEGOTIATIONS.
IN THE END, THIS DEAL IS MEANT
TO BE FOR THE ENTIRE WORLD TO